>> Dagen: PRESIDENT BIDEN
PLAYING DEFENSE WITH POTENTIAL
OF DISASTER TO A LOOM.
THE TELE- BAND GAINING MOMENTUM
WITH PROOF WITHDRAWAL IS 90%
COMPLETE.
PRESIDENT BIDEN ADDRESSING THE
PLAN EARLIER AND GETTING NASTY
WITH THE PRESS BY THE REPORTERS.
>> IT IS TALIBAN TAKEOVER OF
AFGHANISTAN NOW INEVITABLE?
>> NO, IT IS NOT.
BECAUSE YOU HAVE THE AFGHAN
TROOPS WITH 300,000 WELL
EQUIPPED, AS WELL-EQUIPPED AS
ANY ARMY IN THE WORLD.
>> [INDISTINCT]
>> DO I TRUST THE TALIBAN, NO.
I TRUST THE CAPACITY OF THE
AFGHAN MILITARY WHO IS BETTER
TRAINED, BETTER EQUIPPED, AND
MORE COMPETENT IN TERMS OF
CONDUCTING WAR.
>> THE UNITED STATES WILL YOU
HOLD RESPONSIBLE FOR CIVILIAN
LIVES AFTER?
>> NO, NO, NO.
>> THE PRESS WAS ON THE BALL.
>> Dana: THOSE WERE THE
TOUGHEST QUESTIONS HE HAS HAD AN
WHO SERVED BUSH, OBAMA, HE WROTE
HIS BOOK AND SAID, HIS WORDS NOT
MINE, JOE BIDEN HAS BEEN WRONG
ON EVERY FOREIGN POLICY ISSUE
SINCE '70s.
I WILL NOT DEBATE WHETHER TO
LEAVE AFGHANISTAN.
THE DECISION IS MADE BUT YOU CAN
LEAVE IN A WAY THAT HIS DIGNITY
AND NOT SLOPPY.
THE OTHER THING THAT IS
BOTHERING ME IS THE ISSUE OF THE
AFGHAN INTERPRETERS, WHO
SACRIFICED WORKS FOR US AND YOU
HAVE PEOPLE LIKE CONGRESSMAN
MICHAEL WALTZ AND DAN CRENSHAW
WHO BOTH SERVED AND WILL SAY
THERE INTERPRETERS SAVE THEIR
LIVES.
THEY ARE SUPPOSED TO BE ABLE TO
COME HERE AND BECAUSE THE
TALIBAN WANTED TO KILL THEM.
AND SO THERE IS A WHOLE BUNCH
OVER THERE BUT THIS CASE IS
BOTHERING ME THIS WEEK IS THERE
IS A MAN NAME...
HE LIVES IN IOWA SINCE 2014 HE
CAME FOR A CONFERENCE AND FOUND
OUT THE TALIBAN WOULD TRY TO
KILL HIM.
HE FILED FOR POLITICAL ASYLUM,
LIVING IN IOWA, HE HAS A
BUSINESS, EMPLOYEES, HE GOES IN
FOR HIS INTERVIEW.
AND FINALLY TO GET HIS APPROVAL
TUESDAY.
THEY SAID "THE DEPARTMENT OF
HOMELAND SECURITY, HAVE YOU EVER
HAD INTERACTION WITH TALIBAN?"
I CAN'T TELL A LIE WHEN I WAS
NINE YEARS OLD THE TALIBAN CAME
TO ME AND SAID I HAD TO GO GET A
PIECE OF BREAD.
I WENT TO MY MOM, GOT THE BREAD
AND MY MOM YELLED AND CALLED
THEM SMUGGLERS.
OKAY, HE WAS NINE YEARS OLD.
THE DEPARTMENT OF HOMELAND
SECURITY SENT HIM A LETTER THAT
SAYS "BECAUSE OF YOUR
INTERACTION WITH THE TALIBAN,
YOU ARE NOT ALLOWED TO STAY."
THEY ARE GOING TO DEPORT HIM.
ON THIS RIDICULOUS TECHNICALITY.
THE WHITE HOUSE SAID, THAT IS
WHAT THE LAW SAYS.
I THINK THAT IS EXTREMELY HARD
TO BELIEVE.
I HOPE SOMEONE IS ACTUALLY
TELLING THE PRESIDENT WHAT IS
REALLY GOING ON HERE BECAUSE
SOMEBODY NEEDS TO GET SECRETARY
MAYORKAS TO SAY THAT IS
SHAMEFUL.
IT IS SHAMEFUL THEY DON'T HAVE A
PATH TO PROTECT THE
INTERPRETERS, GERALDO.
>> Dagen: IT SEEMS HAPHAZARD
AND THEY MOVE THE DATE UP TO
AUGUST 31ST BECAUSE SOMEBODY
TOLD THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION
"HEY, 9/11 LOOKS BAD AND LOOKS
LIKE A MARKETING PLOY.
>> Geraldo: A COUPLE OF QUICK
POINTS.
THIS IS JOE BIDEN AT HIS
FINANCE.
YOU MAY DISAGREE WITH HIM BUT HE
WAS STRONG, COMMITTED, DOING
SOMETHING CONTROVERSIAL BUT THE
BEST INTEREST OF THE
UNITED STATES.
WE WENT TO AFGHANISTAN TO AVENGE
9/11.
WE KILLED BIN LADEN AND GREAT TO
BE ON THE AIR AND BREAK THAT
NEWS TO THE NATION THAT
BIN LADEN HAD BEEN KILLED BY OUR
GREAT SEAL WARRIORS.
WE SHOULD HAVE LEFT THEM IN
2011.
WE STAYED TEN YEARS TOO LONG.
AFGHAN IS A FAILED STATE.
IT IS A NARCO STATE THAT
PROVIDES HERO WHEN CONSUMED
EUROPE.
ONCE I WAS WITH THE MARINES AND
THE PROVINCE AND THEY WERE
CAMPING AND POPPY FIELDS.
IT IS A DISGUSTING, SAVAGE
PLACE.
IT WILL SPLINTER PEER THERE WAS
NO HOLDING IT TOGETHER.
IN TERMS OF I HAVE OUR DEAR
INTERPRETER, MIKE GUY THAT SAVED
MY LIFE, SAME THING.
WE WORKED WITH SKY NEWS AND THEY
TALK TO THE TALIBAN.
YOU CAN GET THEM ON THE
TELEPHONE.
SO NOW, HE HAS TO STRAIGHTEN
THAT ALL OUT BEFORE HE CAN GET
HERE.
WE KNOW ON A FIRST-NAME BASIS
THAT RISKED EVERYTHING.
HAVING SAID THAT, I ALSO WANT TO
SAY, MY GOD, G.I.s MO WARRIORS
WHO SOME GAVE THEIR LIVES, GET E
WITH WAR CORRESPONDENT, AND YOU
INTERVIEWED EHRMAN SO-AND-SO AND
HE DIED HERE AND THERE.
IT IS A HORRIBLE EXPERIENCE AND
WE SHOULD HAVE LEARNED FROM THAT
ALEXANDER THE GREAT AND THE
BRITISH EMPIRE AND THE
SOVIET UNION THAT YOU CAN'T
REMAKE A COUNTRY AND OUR OWN
IMAGE.
YOU WILL NEVER MAKE AFGHANISTAN
FRANCE.
FORGET ABOUT IT.
YOU KNOW, LET'S CUT OUR LOSSES.
>> Dagen: THE STORY BECOMES
CHINA, CHINA RAMPING UP
AFGHANISTAN INVOLVEMENT AND U.S.
WITHDRAWAL.
AFGHANISTAN IS NO LONGER AT THE
NATIONAL, STRATEGIC INTEREST
SAID PRESIDENT BIDEN TODAY.
OH, REALLY RADICAL ISLAMIC
TERRORISM?
YOU HAVE THE TALIBAN AND
AL QAEDA AND ISIS.
>> Jesse: THEY HAVE A HANDLE
ON IT.
GERALDO WAS RIGHT, JOE BIDEN WAS
MORE COHERENT THAN I HAVE EVER
SEEN HIM.
AND THAT IS JUST BECAUSE I COULD
UNDERSTAND WHAT JOE WAS SAYING
AND THAT IS A LOW BAR AND AS
COMPLEMENT AS I WILL BE WITH THE
PRESIDENT.
AND ALSO GERALDO, HE GOT BOUNCED
OUT OF THERE TOO COME A BAD
TRACK RECORD APPEAR AT THE TRAIN
IS DISGUSTING, CAVES, MOUNTAINS,
DESERTS, THE EXPORT OPM DRUGS
POVERTY-STRICKEN AND I
DON'T KNOW HOW YOU CAN FIGHT
THERE.
YOU CAN SPEND THE NEXT ENTRY
GUNNING DOWN TALIBAN IN
AFGHANISTAN AND THE PLACE WOULD
BE THE SAME PEER THERE IS REALLY
NO DIFFERENCE IF YOU LOOK AT
VIETNAM AND AFGHANISTAN.
NOT WINNABLE WARS, NIXON
RECOGNIZED IT IN THE VIETNAM
HIDING UNDERGROUND IN TUNNELS,
JUNGLES OF SIMULATING ON THE
POPULATION AND JUMP OUT ANY TIME
AND SHOOT AGI.
YOU WILL NEVER WIN THE
TRADITIONAL SENSE.
THE TELEGRAM ONLY FOR US RIGHT
NOW IN PLAY, THEY RECONSTITUTED
COMING RECONSTITUTED, INEVITABLE
BUT THE ISSUE IS, HOW HARD WHAT
WE HAVE TO DIG AND TO DEFEND THE
EMBASSY IN KABUL?
THAT IS THE BIG ISSUE, BUT
THANKS TO GEORGE W. BUSH AND A
SITTING PRESIDENT, WE HAVE SET
UP SUCH A GREAT COUNTERTERROR
SYSTEM, THE SATELLITES, THE
FINANCIAL TRACKING SYSTEMS,
INTERROGATION DRONES, ALL SORTS
OF TECHNOLOGY THAT WE CAN RELATE
THIS CORRUPT AS THEY ARE COMING
TOGETHER.
SO HOPEFULLY WE CAN PROTECT THE
HOMELAND FROM HERE.
>> Dagen: GERALDO LIKED
PRESIDENT BIDEN'S PERFORMANCE
TODAY, BUT THAT WAS HUMBLING AND
INCOHERENT AND FELL A LOT OF
TIMES.
>> Geraldo: SO DID JESSE.
>> Jesse: BETTER THAN HE HAS
BEEN BEFORE.
I DIDN'T SAY GOOD BUT BETTER.
>> Geraldo: I DON'T KNOW, YOU
KNOW, I GIVE HIM A PASS BECAUSE
20 YEARS HAS A LONG TIME.
AND WE HAVE TO ACCEPT THAT THE
WORLD HAS CHANGED, ESPECIALLY
WITH WARFARE AND TECHNOLOGY.
WE'VE GOT TO GET OVER THIS IDEA
IT IS A FAILURE TO LEAVE.
IT IS NOT A FAILURE TO LEAVE.
IT IS ACKNOWLEDGMENT THAT THE
WORLD HAS CHANGED.
MAYBE THIS KIND OF WARFARE WE
ARE DEALING WITH IS ALMOST
IRRELEVANT AND EQUATED WHEN YOU
TALK ABOUT THE DRONES AND YOU
TALK ABOUT THE THREATS THAT WE
ARE SEEING WITH RANSOMWARE WHICH
WE CAN'T GET A HANDLE ON.
WE NEED TO CONCENTRATE ON
RANSOMWARE AND BIOTERROR,
DRONES, THINGS LIKE THAT.
THE WAY TO LOOK AT IT,
AFGHANISTAN IS NOT GOING
ANYWHERE, BUT THANKS TO
TECHNOLOGY, WE CAN GO ANYWHERE.
THAT MEANS, YOU KNOW, WE DON'T
HAVE TO BE THERE.
WE MAY NOT HAVE TO OCCUPY
ANYPLACE ANYMORE TO KEEP US
SAFE.
AND I THINK WE KIND OF KNEW
THAT.
AND I THINK IT IS TIME.
PEOPLE SHOULD NOT THINK OF THIS
IS ANY KIND OF DEFEAT.
IT IS JUST THAT THE WORLD HAS
CHANGED.
TERRORISM IS DIFFERENT.
DRONES, BIOTERRORISM, IT HAS ALL
CHANGED.
WHY ARE WE THERE?
WE DON'T HAVE TO BE.
SO ANYWAY.
>> Dagen: I'M JUST CURIOUS HOW
CHINA LEVERAGES THAT AGAINST US.
THEY WANT TO DOMINATE T